this is a Fox News Alert i'm kimberly
guilfoyle and this is the 5:00 news is
breaking on multiple fronts and we begin
tonight with the continued catastrophic
flooding unfolding in Texas rain from
tropical storm harvey continues to pour
on the Lone Star State and now also on
Louisiana with the stalled storm causing
waters to rise to near biblical levels
President Trump is scheduled to travel
to Texas tomorrow to witness the
devastation firsthand to the people of
Texas and Louisiana we are 100% with you
we're praying for you we're working
closely with your leaders and officials
and I will be visiting the impact zone
tomorrow to ensure that you're receiving
full support and cooperation from the
federal government and on Saturday we
think we're going back to Texas and also
we will be going to Louisiana we have
reporters all over the region and we
begin with Steve Harrigan in Rosenberg
Texas see Kimberly
this is just like standing under a
faucet it just doesn't stop it's coming
in sideways it's been coming in sideways
since dawn it's cold this is nine inches
of rain in the past 24 hours alone what
does that mean it means conditions here
around Houston in the suburbs getting
worse every hour neighborhood after
neighborhood now in the dark declaring
mandatory evacuations it's getting much
more dangerous city officials now saying
they will not be able to help people in
certain to these neighborhoods it's
simply too tough to get around and you
can see many of the roads being flooded
behind me actually we've been watching a
giant sinkhole grow that's because so
much war has been dumped in this area
there are real questions about the
structural soundness of small bridges
the shelters are filling up you have to
call ahead of time they're even turning
furniture stores in the shelter's people
are arriving wet and cold when you see
people around they just look stunned
looking for something to eat looking for
clothing the shelters have put outward
they need doctors they need nurses they
need baby formula Kimberly back to you
Wow all right thanks
a great job reporting for us let's go to
trace Gallagher who is in The Woodlands
Texas which is just north of Houston
okay
yeah Kimberly we're about 40 miles north
of where Steve Harrigan just gave you
his report and it's kind of a little bit
of a different situation up here because
the rain has died down really for the
first time in several hours I mean it
was an absolute deluge here all day long
we had flooding we saw homes under water
there were cars under water parking lots
they shut down one of the main
interstates that runs from out here in
woodlands one of the suburbs of Houston
into downtown Houston it's going to be
bearish for people to try to get
anywhere near the city we should point
out they're trying to avoid exactly
what's going on down there in Houston
and the suburbs below there by doing the
opposite they are evacuating a number of
neighborhoods up here about 20 miles
north of us because they're very
concerned about one of the rivers which
is overflowing its banks they're trying
to let as much water as they possibly
can out but they're already at record
levels out they can only let so much
they're getting people out of there just
in case the river overflows the banks
west of Houston very much the same story
getting people out of their homes now
before any chance of flooding
we should note we the rescue totals have
now gone up as of right now they've
rescued some 3050 or so people that's
about a thousand up from the number we
were given just early this morning so
about a thousand rescues today alone
they have mobilized three thousand Texas
National Guardsmen for this effort but
they have every single National Guard
12,000 of them will be involved in this
effort and now we're being told the
Border Patrol is also being mobilized
they're pulling them away from the
border to come up to Houston and help
out in this massive effort they keep
telling us the rain is going to slow
down and eventually go away but today we
saw very little sign of that Kimberly
all right thanks trace for that and
now hear from Caroline Shively who is in
Houston inside the convention center
where people are still taking shelter of
Caroline either kimberly we've just
stepped out on the backside of the
convention center to show you a very
unusual helicopter landing pad they've
created one out of an interstate this is
i 45 it's the Pierce elevator landing if
you know this part of the road we've
seen helicopters coming through here
they're landing dead-on in the middle of
the interstate they have been plucking
folks off roofs people who can't get to
those high water vehicles people who are
past the point where they can be rescued
by boats they've had the helicopters
they put it down we have some video
earlier of one of the helicopters we
have seen Red Cross helicopters National
Guard helicopters other military
helicopters come in they touch down and
you see the people run off of there
clutching their belongings clothing
anything they could get ahold of then
they go to the buses and the buses can
get them here to the Convention Center
5500 people have already gone here into
the convention center that is above
capacity 5000 is what the max was they
said but they're not closing these doors
any buses that come any people who come
on fit foot here in the convention
center they're taking you in even by
helicopter now Kimberly back to you
thanks Caroline a lot of news out of the
White House tonight and for the very
latest is ready okay let's go to Ed
Henry in Washington various hey Kimberly
good to see the president will be joined
on his trip to Texas tomorrow by First
Lady Melania Trump significant because
she's been known for her compassion
taking time out to visit children's
hospitals on her early trips overseas
with the president tomorrow they will be
in Texas trying to deal with the fallout
from the storm important to note they
will be meeting with the governor of
Texas in Austin not going to Euston
because the president does not want his
security needs to overwhelm first
responders on the ground their time of
course better spent on search-and-rescue
efforts that are painfully are still
going on this is all hands on deck for
the administration vice president Mike
Pence today traveled to FEMA
headquarters for briefings he also did a
series of radio interviews where he
estimated a shocking number about half a
million Americans the vice president
said will get
some kind of federal assistance after
the cleanup from this storm that's
consistent with the president with what
the president said at a news conference
at the White House where he said the
administration will do will stop at
nothing to help we see neighbor helping
neighbor friend helping friend and
stranger helping stranger and you see
that all of you watch on television you
just see such incredible work and love
and teamwork we are one American family
we hurt together we struggle together
and believe me we endured together now
all as all this plays out here in the
United States the president still
dealing with the crisis in North Korea
in the last few hours the communist
nation fired a missile over Japan the
Prime Minister of Japan Shinzo Abe a
calling this quote the most serious and
grave threat that his nation has faced
yet in this entire standoff the missile
we should report broke into three
different pieces before falling into the
Pacific Ocean
it does not appear to have injured
anyone or done any damage to Japanese
assets but a sign that this whole
situation is far from over
meanwhile NBC News reporting tonight
that Robert Muller the special counsel
of course is now looking at whether or
not President Trump was involved in a
knowingly false statement when he helped
craft the initial response to his son
Donald Trump's jr. statement about that
meeting last summer at Trump Tower with
the Russian lawyer I'm getting strong
pushback tonight from people in the
president's inner circle trying to shoot
down this report saying that the
president did not commit any kind of
crime that he had a very small amount of
time spent in crafting that statement
about his son's meeting at Trump Tower
and they think in the end the special
counsel will find nothing Kimberly
alright thank that for that update
pleasure to have you okay let's take it
around the table great you want to talk
about the storm the aftermath and what
people are experiencing now we'll talk
about that well it really does make you
question the portrayal of a divided
nation which you know all of us kind of
contribute to and it made me think about
where do you where do you seek out moral
guidance and you don't need it from a
political leader I don't think you need
or guidance from a political leader I
don't think you need it from a religious
leader I think with you look around you
and you look at the people there
Americans can handle massive
catastrophes pretty damn good without
inspiration they are not inspired to do
that they're just naturally doing that
you couple that with the nature of our
system the United States if you compare
a catastrophes of a similar kind country
by country thousands upon thousands are
killed millions are injured in end but
for some reason in a system like ours
which is so resilient which is a
decentralized free market system that
makes it easier for first rescues for
housing to be found for for supplies to
be delivered for evacuations to be made
quickly it's because of a system that is
decentralized that people can come from
all over and do things and it's a rich
country so it when you have these two
kinds of things where you have a free
marketing / free people you have a
system that is that that works even when
it's called xenophobic or bigoted in
seemingly impossible times this
xenophobic bigoted country goes out and
saves people of every color you have
black people save you white people white
people saving black people there is no
color there's no identity politics
there's nothing like that all you see
are humans doing the right thing and
it's system that benefits doing the
right thing
it really does give you a pause to
reflect on what matters in life you see
this kind of human suffering then you
see people coming together putting their
lives on the line like those that serve
our country to try to save to make a
difference someone who's in peril it
certainly makes you count your blessings
right that start complaining during the
day you realize it could be a whole lot
worse but one thing I think that's been
interesting looking at the coverage of
this and listening to the officials on
the ground talking to local communities
they have told them directly do not wait
on us to come rescue you if you have a
neighbor who can help you jump in the
boat if you have boats come and get in
don't wait for us to get there because
we have limited resources and the only
way that you're going to be able to get
out a lot of these situations is by
relying on your fellow Houstonian to get
you out I think the president's visit is
obviously going to be important for
political reasons obviously because we
live in that kind of environment but he
is going to feel humbled I think when he
gets to the ground and sees
devastation but also some kind of hope
and American experience and a healthy
American attitude when it comes to
helping each other yeah very much so so
this is a good opportunity for the
president to show his compassionate but
he likes to rise to the occasion
especially when he sees it you know a
nation and states in peril so far I
think the federal response has been very
effective and there's been great
coordination among the local and state
authorities with the feds hopefully we
can maintain that because it looks like
from based on these pictures the worst
is yet to come for some of these people
but I do think that Harvey has shown
what Texas is made out of it's
unbelievable the kind of the quiet grit
determination the compassion the
resilience that these people are showing
and it's not just the Texas National
Guard it's not just the local police and
fire departments it's your average Joe
on the street sacrificing himself to go
help a neighbor and it's just an amazing
to see in Texas is so independent you
know they're not complaining there's not
a lot of hysteria there's not a lot of
whining it's just this quiet
determination where people are helping
each other out it's also really
refreshing to not see a lot of armchair
quarterbacking going on not a lot of
politicians are politicizing this you
know the mayor of Houston is a Democrat
the governor is a Republican there's not
a lot of second-guessing going on I
can't believe I'm seeing this in America
it's just absolutely baffling stay that
way will it stay that way we will see
and no looting so far I guess if you're
a looter in Texas some bad things can
happen to you haven't seen a lot of
price gouging either that's a shock but
I think that speaks to the spirit of
Texas I've seen some amazing things out
there just looking at television over
the weekend alligators on people's back
doorsteps I saw a shark on a highway
swimming in the water heater like
sharknado
I saw a hawk sitting in someone's
taxicab Greg and I were saying you know
the president was using the term
biblical well there's some really weird
biblical things that are going on down
there in Houston I just I can't even
imagine how I would be experiencing that
as a guy from the Northeast but I think
Texas has it figured out and God bless
them yeah absolutely and you know when
you look at the numbers and we have some
interesting statistics your 450,000
people are likely richer to seek federal
aid so these are people in need and that
30,000 people seek emergency shelter and
75,000 9-1-1 calls can you imagine no I
mean I've lived in one of these things
I'm from Miami so I've lived through
Hurricane Andrew my mom is a registered
nurse so I know what it is to not have
your your parent there my mom would
leave us and go actually go to the
hospital and be there overnight there's
a critical care nurse how people yeah so
I'm shout out to all the nurses and
doctors who spend the night in the
hospital I'm so big shout out to them
and doing what they do but this is a
it's we're all houston strong tonight
where my houston colors Houston rocket
colors tonight because of that and I
want to give a big shout out to all
those individuals for working those
extra hours to make sure the volunteers
the the police officers the firefighters
we're doing yeoman's work um you guys
get a big round of applause for me and
all the Americans all across the country
tonight all the first responders you
always remember them you know in these
times of need but let's also remember
them and their families and their
families who sacrifice a lot like you
had to when your mother went to go
answer the call to help other people so
important life lessons were reminded of
but once again